President Trump is taking his America
first message on the road in less than
two hours from now he's going to be
firing up the crowd in Tampa Florida to
drum up support for gubernatorial
candidate
congressman Ron De Santis we've seen a
dramatic turnaround in the polls after
Trump endorsed him the Sanders is
getting a lot of attention for this
phony Pro Trump campaign ad everyone
knows my husband Ron De Santis is
endorsed by President Trump but he's
also an amazing dad Ron loves playing
with the kids build the wall he reads
the stories then mr. Trump said you're
fired I love that part he's teaching
Madison to talk make America great again
people say Ron's all Trump but he is so
much more
big-league so good I just thought you
should know
oh gosh can congressman's this and this
isn't the only candidate benefiting from
Trump's backing the president is on an
endorsement hot streak candidates he has
supported have won nine out of the last
ten contested races including all
primaries the question is will Democrats
be able to stop this momentum in the
midterms Juan Williams
so when Donald Trump goes out on the
stump and he holds these big rallies
he's very entertaining and he sucks up a
lot of the oxygen he dominates the local
media markets and he raises a lot of
money he's funny out there does that
something the Democrats look at and fear
or do they want Trump you know in the
spotlight I think they welcome it and in
fact you know so that you talk about the
streak that Trump has I want to go back
to Abe Lincoln because Trump says he's
more popular among Republicans than Abe
Lincoln and Jesse even for you I think
that's a bit much for Honest Abe I don't
know I don't know we have to go back and
see if we can find a pole for Abe
Lincoln but anyway Trump assures us he
was probably a Rasmussen I'm sure and
I'm sure that you would cite it so I
think that the what goes on here is
we've come into the era of the Trump
Republican cult everything Trump Trump
backs a candidate Trump's candidate mitt
Lee takes off even in this case where
there was a really
popular Republican running a guy who had
been elected for 21 years in the state
of Florida a veteran all of a sudden
DeSantis shows up on Fox a lot and then
gets endorsed by a trump tweet and he's
the candidate all of a sudden his
numbers jump but I think it's really
telling these guys aren't running on the
economy they're not running on tax cuts
they're running on anti-immigrant fervor
they're running on things like putting
down the NFL players so this is what
we've got
I think fine I think Democrats know that
if you look at Virginia and that
gubernatorial race you look at the
Alabama Senate race you look at
Pennsylvania 18 this is not Trump's time
not when it gets to the general he might
dominate in the primary right but not in
the junk what do you think about Trump
in the general with these Trump pack
candidates well I think it's interesting
because the 2018 midterms are being
fought in two different battlegrounds
and both can be seen in Florida where
the president will be tonight so one of
them would be the congressman Carlos
Cabello he's a respected member of
Congress but he is probably the most
endangered Republican and what he's had
to do in his district which is down to
Miami is to try to distance himself from
President Trump and so there's that one
okay so presidents will come to me in
Tampa that's not necessarily the miami
media market but still he goes there
contrast that with rick scott who's
running for the senate he's currently
the governor he wants to beat bill
Nelson for that Senate seat and he is
unabashedly Pro make America great again
and he is up in the polls so you have
these two things where Scott needs him
in Carmelo needs to distance himself
from him both could theoretically work
right
both people could end up winning that
their diamond diametrically opposed
strategy but it does show the power and
the threat of President Trump do you see
it that way
well you know the argument did obviously
there are some areas in Virginia in
places like that where Donald Trump is
unpopular but the fact that he got he
got elected despite that unpopularity
just underscores I think a very
important thing that gets gets missed a
lot and that is for all the excitement
and weirdness of the 2060
election it was all about issues and a
lot of people came out and voted for
Trump they didn't like him and they
didn't like some of the stuff he did but
they cared about it's not anti-immigrant
fervor they cared about illegal
immigration they cared about trade they
cared about the economy and they said on
these issues I think this guy you know
he may not be somebody I want to invite
to my tea party or have a beer with or
whatever although I can't imagine any
true American not wanting to have a beer
with Donald Trump
if you drink or anything but but the
fact that they they trusted him on those
issues and he was talking about issues
that these people had that Republicans
and Democrats had both seated and you
take a guy like Adam Putnam in Florida
who was a very popular politician from
there but that hurts him the fact that
he was in Washington so long because he
hadn't been bringing up these issues in
Trump you know sloshes in and brings all
up all these issues that we're not
supposed to be talking I was thinking
about what you're saying just give me a
second you know we can't wait to hear
your point but I just wanted to rebut
Carly while I had the metaphor that when
you think about Republican Party stances
I would think about free trade right I
would think about being open to
immigration as being part of the history
so that's why I think we've remade the
Republican Party into the image of
Donald Trump the only thing I would say
about that and I'll let Katie take the
floor here I believe the only thing that
can really hurt the president in the
midterms are two things the enthusiasm
gap right if the Democrats are just
rabid and they come out so strong and
just overwhelm Republicans or the trade
issue because if he doesn't score trade
winds between now and November a lot of
the white working-class voters are
affected by the free trade situation
right now or may stay home and trade is
a local issue right and midterm
elections are all about turnout so when
we talk about President Trump going to
Florida having this rally Phil Keating
was reporting there earlier saying that
people camped out overnight they're
excited to be there they're going to be
thousands of people there to support him
the Sanchez has been accused of being in
Washington for far too long but he can
make the argument that he's going to be
a candidate like Donald Trump the son
she's going to keep his promises if he
the governorship and he can governor
like an executive as the president has
on a number of issues and you can take
the trunk platform with illegal
immigration law and order tax cuts
deregulation and apply them in a local
sense so in that perspective he may have
some time for another thing to yours the
two things that could hurt the president
and I'm a little bit of a broken record
on it because I don't think I have
gotten the message through and that is
the registering of new voters because
the Democrats are really good at it
they're super organized with it about it
and Republicans need to do the same
these people they do that they're gonna
rally like this well these people
already probably voters that's the thing
so you got to find the new voters where
can you find them new voters are usually
enthusiastic voters mmm and so that's
why you saw like in Virginia and
Gillespie has more Republicans turnout
than ever in the history of the state
and he loses by nine points if you look
at the total electorate 12% of those
voters in Virginia had never voted in a
gubernatorial election before so you've
got to try to find those new voters
because the Democrats are definitely a
good trail race is very different than a
congressional race for many different
reasons and congressional races are far
more specific on issues than a
governorship would be and we're looking
at the crowd right now starting to
gather in Tampa for this big Trump rally
Charlie what do you think he's gonna say
tonight he's given one of these every
two to three weeks this year is there
gonna be new material is it going to be
the same old razzle-dazzle what do you
expect her I think there will be some
new material but I also think that one
of the really appealing things about
about Donald Trump all along is the fact
that he has actually brought in new
voters people that haven't voted before
or that have been apathetic which the
Obama voters and they became but you but
but you know you'd walk into a truck
stop in the middle of the 2016 election
and you'd walk by a couple of guys that
had never you know that you'd talk to
him and they'd never voted before and
then we talk about what Donald Trump had
said the night before or you know that
they listen to on the radio and they and
and and that I think under any you know
and it was like with President Obama in
2008 where you he was he was running
this very different campaign as a very
hopeful campaign unlike the 2012
campaign but is very hopeful and he was
bringing in new
people that had had we're very cynical
about politics and that and in both
cases I think it's very good for this
office to get new people so the man who
usually sits in your seat Charlie mr.
Gutfeld often says to me America is
watching two movies and it's not the
same movie but their running is like hey
I see something differently in the you
do and in this case the other side the
flip side of what you're talking about
is that Trump activates the Democratic
base in a big way that's why that's that
enthusiasm gap and if you look at the
overall poll numbers right now remember
for a while people are saying oh he's at
forty five that's the highest he's ever
been he's now starting to go back down
and his disapproval rating still 50
something percent so as we talk about
the different races I think you have to
understand that maybe the Trump movie
for a lot of people is playing out
because he's very entertaining you said
he's very funny I here's what I would
say I would say for the Trump voters the
movies an action thriller and for the
Democrats it's a horror flick but you
brought up some approval numbers and we
ran some numbers through the waters
matrix historically yeah okay we didn't
go that far back
okay we don't have a time machine but in
the big kind of wave elections where
Democrats picked up a lot of House seats
and in 2006 and 2008 they picked up
about twenty to thirty seats or
something like that the generic
congressional ballot had Democrats up
thirteen to fifteen points going in now
there were only up about seven points so
historically that's not gonna be enough
for them to pick up enough seats in the
house to retake it and the president's
going to be extremely involved in flying
all around the country he said he's
going to be on the road six to seven
days a week campaigning the question
will be I think that he can we'll see if
we can keep up it as an investment in
his agenda long term so yes he'll be on
the road for two three months but
they're seeing it as we have to make
sure we keep the house in order to make
sure the agenda moves forward long-term
and so Democrats don't move forward with
some kind of impeachment process and you
know Donald Trump's numbers may be
upside down but you know whose are even
more upside down Nancy Pelosi and I
think that we'll start seeing Maxine
Waters
getting polled those those people have
been running campaigns against them for
a long time and they're still doing it
yeah that's that but that's the fair
factor so you asked you know will we see
new stuff at the campaign tonight at the
campaign rally in Florida I suspect
it'll be the same old stuff about
immigrants right
it'll be about me immigrants about
illegal aliens
oh no I keep saying at this table this
is my Dana Perino moment I keep saying
listen you guys don't listen but he
wants to cut legal immigration in this
country all right that's another topic
for another day one got it wrong